Welcome to the
Joma show, the show
where we talk about
tips and tricks
on how to land a
successful career in tech.
In this show, sometimes
I have guests.
Sometimes I don't, like today,
I don't have any guests.
Most of the time I will
not have any guests.
Because Silicon Valley
people are quite busy.
So today we're going
to talk about how
to land your first internship.
And how am I going
to talk about this?
I'm going to talk
about through my lens,
through my experiences.
Rather than telling
you what to do,
I'll just tell you
exactly what I did.
And not saying that's
the best way to do it,
but I'm sharing my story.
After this video, I'm
going to talk about
all my other internships.
For example, how to get
internship at Citadel.
How to get an
internship at LinkedIn.
How to transition into
data science at Facebook.
And then how to transition
again into PM at Microsoft.
So if you're interested
in all those companies,
don't forget to press subscribe
so that you get notified
when those companies come up.
Welcome to the Joma show.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Before I start, I
just want to say
that I'm not going to tell you,
oh yeah, just work hard, do
practice questions
and stuff like that.
The way I got things,
it's not 100% merit.
I use a lot of my
brothers connections.
I exaggerated my resume a lot.
And I also put projects that I
never completed but said I did.
To be honest, I don't
want my friends knowing.
It's embarrassing.
Which is why I'm not promoting
this channel to them.
But I'm telling you guys.
Because I want to be
fully transparent.
Or else, in the
end, I'm only going
to be talking about vague shit.
And I don't want to
talk about vague shit.
I just want to talk
about concrete things
on exactly how to get
those internships.
All right.
So let's get started.
I'm going to look at my
old resume for reference.
Because it's been a while.
And I don't remember
what exactly I did.
So as you can see, I wrote
a lot of cover letters.
That's how I started.
But I just want to
look at my resume.
I think it's this one.
I'm not sure.
It might be this one.
Yeah, that's it.
So work experience, I still
had no work experience.
I worked at McDonald's
and Statistics Canada.
I just knock on people's doors.
Let's see.
This sounds about right.
Nah, actually, I'm going
to take the longer one.
Is it this one?
I had multiple resumes.
So the first thing I learned
about getting internship
is they told me to make
my resume one page.
Because they don't have enough
time to read all of them.
So I have one resume where
I just have everything
that I've accomplished.
And then I shorten
it depending on if I
want to apply for
finance or software.
Let me just try to
remember what I did.
Cool.
I think I remember now.
All right.
My first exposure into
programming was CRC Robotics.
This is something that
I did in high school.
It's not really high school.
It's Cegep.
Because I'm from Quebec.
But you don't need
to know what that is.
CRC Robotics, basically,
we had to build robots.
And then we compete
against each other.
And so for example,
one of the tests
was that you had to program
your robot to autonomously do
a few things.
So that's where
programming came along.
So that was my first exposure.
It was called ROBOTC
apparently, the language.
It just looks like C++.
And then my brother
was also graduating
from Waterloo, which is the
school that I was going to go,
University of Waterloo.
And then he told me
about computer science.
He said, oh, you could have
this thing called code programs
where you could write
stuff and then you
could input stuff and
then output stuff.
I thought it was the
most boring shit ever.
But he told me that you
could get pretty sick jobs
at Facebook and stuff like that.
So then I started
learning something
called DrRacket or Scheme,
which is fucking stupid.
Because I don't think
any company uses it.
So I don't know why
I was learning that.
But apparently that's the first
thing you learn at school.
The first course is
called CS135 or something.
And then I dabble into that.
And then I learned about
Python and what Python was.
So then I was doing Harvard
classes online, the really easy
ones.
OK, they're not really easy.
Because I did the first course.
I thought it was bomb.
And then when it comes
to object oriented shit,
I'm like, what the fuck?
I just couldn't understand.
I didn't even pass that level.
So I had a very basic
literacy of Python.
Oh, yeah.
True.
I have to talk about my school.
Because I think that's
an important piece.
So I went to
University of Waterloo.
I could tell you
how I got in there.
But you probably don't need to.
Because it's super
easy to get into.
Waterloo is pretty
special in the fact
that you have to do five to
six internships before you
graduate.
So they have this
system called Job Mine.
And you have to apply to
jobs using that system
every other semester.
And it makes getting
internships a lot easier.
So if you have something
like that in school,
make sure you take
advantage of it.
Because that's
usually how you'll
get your first tech internship.
Your first internship is
usually the hardest one.
Because you have no experience.
And you only have side projects.
If you have bomb
ass side projects,
it's going to be
pretty easy for you.
If you don't, you
should do some.
You don't need to finish them.
To be honest, you could
even lie a little bit.
But just make sure
that when you're
asked questions about it,
you can answer them fully.
So fast forward to a year.
It's job fair.
I mean, we don't
call it job fair.
We have some program called
Job Mine where you just
put your resume, put
your cover letter,
and send it to companies.
Let me show you something.
So here's the folder
that I use to organize
all of the applications.
So I had a cover letter
for each and every company.
It was crazy.
It's basically the same thing.
But I just changed the name
of the company and the reasons
why I'm a good fit.
I think I got a few responses,
maybe 10 responses out of 50.
And then out of
those interviews,
I only got I think
two or three jobs.
I think one was QA position
at some Waterloo company.
I don't remember what it was.
But it was some basic shit.
And then I also got
my first internship,
which is Scotiabank.
So back to my resume.
I'm going to tell you
how I got that, Well, how
I think I got that first job.
It's not exactly
software engineering.
But we did a lot of
I did a lot of C++ there.
I did some VBA coding thing,
which is not something software
people would do.
So not going to lie,
the first job I got,
it's not best job ever.
I mean, Scotiabank, [GAG].
You probably don't even
know what Scotiabank is.
It's a Canadian bank by the way.
Not prestigious at all.
It's crap to be honest.
But the position was quite good.
It's called Credit--
no, what was it again?
Equity and Credit Derivatives.
And I'll tell you a
little bit about that
and how I got into that.
So what Credit and
Derivatives-- oh yeah.
True.
I forgot to talk about this.
I was in math and business.
I wasn't in computer
science back then.
I actually wanted to be an
investment banker or something.
I didn't even want to
be a software engineer.
Mostly I thought I was
going to be and investment
banker or a trader.
So I was really
into finance stuff.
And I did two projects.
So the first project is Intrade.
So Intrade was a website
that you could bet on events.
So how it works is, for
example, if you thought
Obama was going to
win the election,
then you have a
marketplace for that.
For example, if the price is
at $9.00 and you buy at $9
and Obama actually
wins the election,
then it will automatically
go up to $10.
So it's $0 to $10.
So then you would gain $1.
If he'd lost the election,
it will go to $0.
So that means all the
money invested, the $9
invested, you'll lose it
all and it will become $0.
So basically it's
like a stock market.
And then also, my
brother told me that, oh,
it's actually a binary option.
I don't want to bore
you with the details.
But basically, in
a finance world,
whatever I was playing
with in that website
were binary options.
And he told me that,
oh, do you want
to work on a project
together, my brother and I.
And then I said,
yeah, sure, why not.
So then he told me,
oh, why don't you write
a Python bot that trades
these options automatically.
I didn't really know
anything about finance,
but then I learned.
I learned that you could
price a binary option.
I just went to Wikipedia.
You could Google binary option.
And there's something
called a Black-Scholes motto
that you can you
input your numbers
and then have a guesstimate
on how much it would cost.
And usually it would
be pretty accurate.
So we did that for a
couple of months I think.
And it was actually
a really basic bot.
It was terrible actually.
There was no try catch
errors or whatever.
It was pretty shit.
But I still did it.
And we still made money-ish.
So then now I had a pretty
good fundamental knowledge
on options for trading.
And then the second
project, I did RITC.
This is a Rotman International
Trading Competition.
It's not technical at all.
You have Excel spreadsheets.
You write some VBA code to try
to facilitate your trading.
I basically wrote
some VBA macros
to facilitate in our
pricing of the assets
so that we could trade.
I did really well on a case
that was the options case.
So I understood calls and puts.
Ooh.
It's not a lot.
But it's enough to impress
them as a freshman.
I interviewed for Scotiabank.
I also interviewed
for other companies.
But I'll just talk
about Scotiabank.
And then what they
asked me was, first,
they asked me some
C++ related questions.
Oh, what's object
oriented programming
and stuff, inheritance,
and stuff like that.
And then they asked
me some linked lists
questions I remember I think.
And then they also asked
me a binary search problem.
For example, can you
use binary search
to find if a number exists?
I think they give you an
array of assorted number.
So first, the easiest solution
would be just go linearly.
But that would be you have
to know your time complexity
stuff.
So then first to brute force
ways is just scan it linearly.
And then later on they say
can you do it any better?
And then that's where you put
out the binary search method.
And then I think that's it.
That's the hardest
questions there.
So it was pretty simple.
Because it's a finance company.
They don't ask you hard shit.
Next they asked me some
call and put options.
I think they drew a line,
which is the payout line,
and then they told me, oh, what
combination of calls and puts
is that?
And can you tell me
how to combine them
so that your payout
option looks like that?
Sorry that I'm
talking about this.
Because it's not really
software related.
But that's what they asked me.
So then I got that
question right.
And then went home.
And then they called
me back a week later.
And they said that I was the
number one candidate for them.
And then they wanted
to offer me a job.
That was great.
I got the job.
And that's how I got
my first internship.
So that's pretty much it.
Let me see if I forgot anything.
Oh, yeah, true.
So I guess I did a lot
of random shit, too.
And I'll tell you
things that are
iffy that might have helped,
but also might not have helped
and also that I didn't do
but I wrote that I did.
So here you could see I
got a Facebook Hacker Cup.
I wrote annual worldwide program
competition hosted by Facebook.
Develop problem solving
skills through completing
their programming puzzles.
I didn't even do any of them.
I think I did one or two.
I got one of them and then
I failed the other two.
I didn't even make it
to the second round.
Pygame.
I made a stupid ass
game using Pygame.
I think it was just a ball that
runs around and shoots balls
at things.
And then Google AI Challenge.
Oh, that's the worst.
I didn't even do that.
So basically the Google
AI Challenge I remember
was as a game of Plant Wars.
There was another game
like this that you could
play for real, not using bots.
You have planets.
And then you could shoot
spaceships onto another planet
to capture it if you
have more spaceships
than the other planet.
So you could program a
bot to play that game.
But I didn't even do it.
I think I just
downloaded the sample bot
and changed a few parameters
and just tried it out.
But I didn't even know how to
run it or test it and stuff.
So I didn't even do that.
But I still put it in there.
And I also had some stupid
shit just to fill in my resume,
like poker.
Because I thought
that's for trading.
Oh, traders love poker.
So I talked about my poker.
This is actually real.
I'm pretty proud of my poker
games and my profit there.
I even put my art stuff.
I don't know why I put that.
Oh, yeah, I guess I
have to say that I
did get good grades in school.
So that might have helped.
Waterloo, I had
cumulative average of 93.
So I was in Dean's honor list.
Never be discouraged that
your first internship is shit.
Because after you get
one good internship,
all the other big
companies will just
come knocking at your door.
And you just get a
shit ton of interviews.
So in conclusion, that was how
I got my first tech internship.
And it wasn't a great
tech internship.
Because it was a no
name tech internship.
And it was C++ crap.
Code base was shit.
Their tech was really bad.
But it was my first job.
And it led to how
I got into Citadel.
And I'll talk about
that on my next video.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to
subscribe if you want
to know how I got
into Citadel, which
I will post next time I guess.
Thanks for watching.
Peace.
[MUSIC PLAYING]